hast du nicht geschafft toilettenpapier
break start
hallo leute ich es wieder einmal wanne
und ihr seht wo ich mich befinde das
kann nur eins heißen wir testen heute
regale süßigkeiten börse ist original
ich habe die gleichen produkte bei rewe
und wiegens gekauft und auf dem
kassenbon sieht man schon den
allerersten unterschied der ein kopfball
reese hat zehn euro 7 gekostet und der
einkauf bei gegen 20 eur 21 das heißt
schon mal das vegane sachen eigentlich
doppelt so teuer sind und jetzt lasst
uns probieren was besser schmeckt wir
fangen an mit butter keksen vegan versus
original die originalen butterkekse
kosten 89 cent die vegan butterkekse
kosten 1 euro 69 what the [ __ ] warum
sind die doppelt so teuer kostet der
ersatz wirklich so viel ich bin mir da
nicht so sicher näher das werk voll die
kindheitserinnerung man wenn man auch
zum ausflug war dann gab es mal so eine
packung leibnitz und dann hat man kekse
optisch finde ich den veganen pro tag
schöner
man riecht auf jeden fall beim leibniz
butterkeks die butter und hier nicht
zuerst das original so wollte ich immer
schon gestört hat dass man bei den live
and butter keksen immer so backpulver
geschmack im mund ein bisschen diesen
feurigen komischen geschmack und jetzt
testen wir die 1 euro 69 variante es tut
mir wirklich leid aber der vegane
butterkeks hat definitiv gewonnen er ist
viel knuspriger schmeckt irgendwie
einfach viel besser
ein punkt für die veganer hunde zwei
dominosteine daher gerade weihnachtszeit
ist dachte ich mir dominosteine sollte
man definitiv auch test und die veganen
dominosteine sind nicht nur vegan
sondern auch genfrei crazy die original
dominosteine haben 79 cent gekostet und
vegan und glutenfrei dominosteine haben
vier euro 49 gekostet da muss ich aber
sagen ich hab sie auch noch bei edeka
gesehen und nicht bei wiegens und da
haben sie 399 gekostet also wiegens
packt noch mal ordentlich drauf 449
dominosteine hoffe ich kann man sich auf
jeden fall schnell unterscheiden die
veganen steine sind riesengroß bisschen
flacher dafür auch und fliesen halt wie
man dominosteine kennt nicht ein kleines
steinchen die weihnachtszeit auf
angefahren ihr seid super kennt man es
da bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt
gute ihn frei vegan und sonst nix drin
wir gehen auf jeden fall komplett gleich
aus aber die sind schon extrem lecker
ohne hat der klassische dominosteinen
denn das preis leistungsverhältnis
einfach viel besser jetzt kommt der
großvater eine süßigkeiten schokolade
ich zweifel definitiv dass die vegane
schokolade besser schmecken soll akin
originale aber wir lassen uns
überraschen die originale mega
schokolade kostet 1 euro und 9 cent die
vegane variante 1 eur 99 der veganer und
das original im geruchstest sind beide
ganz weit vorne
auch in laos und jetzt kommt der vegane
konkurrent omaha
ich muss sagen das ergebnis ist ganz
schön knapp weil mich die vegane
schokolade komplett überzeugt hat der
geschmack ist wirklich besser als man
erwartet muss ich sagen
trotzdem hat die mehrheit gewonnen weil
ich finde es geht nichts über milka
schokolade doch wer wirklich weniger
tierprodukte zu sich nehmen möchte das
ist eine richtig gute alternative
und auch nicht ganz so teuer einzelne 90
es trotzdem nicht billig aber es ist
okay dann haut man sich davon auch nicht
so viel rein
statt zwei mega tafeln kann man sich
dann eine vegane holen
super runde nummer vier wer kennt sie
nicht die gute prinzenrolle oder bio bis
schokolade biscuit michelangelo die
originale prinzenrolle kostet 129 und
die vegane version 2 eur 19 es ist
wenigstens nicht doppelt so teuer aber
wenn man auf die gramm zahl runter
rechnet wahrscheinlich schwarz ich
natürlich großer unterschied da sehen
wir einen prinzen drauf und hier nicht
ich muss sagen den geschmack und die
besten
ist ok bis in butter und jetzt der
vegane prinz der hat gewonnen
der schmeckt nur noch butter und seiner
leicht zu kriegen cacau masse an der
schmeckt wirklich nachkriegs und so
schmeckt wie schokolade viel leckerer
raus es ist vielleicht auch ein
komischer spruch aber der fühlt sich
besser mund
doch wie sieht es aus bei
karamellbonbons unsere geliebten nun
muss versus kuh bonbon glaube davon ist
auch eine nicht vegane version ich bin
ich ganz sicher muss kosten 199 die
vegan muss kosten 299 schon mal probiert
ich finde die absolute recker wehr
veganer kumpel ist auf jeden fall
dunkler
das riecht mehr nach mich kam deshalb
nicht weil er keine milch drin ist der
geschmack erlaubt du müssen sie auf dem
veganer bin ich jetzt richtig gespannt
schmeckt richtig heiße schmeckt bitter
wie ich süß absolut keine empfehlung es
ist nicht mal ansatzweise so lecker wie
das union wir kommen zurück in
weihnachtsstimmung mit spekulation ganz
normales tier gequält oder spekulation
99 cent 239 für die vegane version
die sind sehr sehr hübsch und der duft
ist sehr intensiv das riecht halbbruder
spielplatzes wurde als spekulant für
butter und einer drin und hier nicht
entnerven biegen virgin ganz klarer
sieger der veganer spekulation also hier
verteile ich eine ganz klare
kaufempfehlung der spekulatius keks mit
gewürzen es wirklich top und wer steigt
als nächstes in den regen für team vegan
und team original
sh mutter versiegen war für schnitte
hasen das original hanuta zwei stück
kosten 59 cent ein stück der vegan
version kostet 89 sind
was kann dollar so teuer sein etwas darf
nicht halt müssen sie ihm alles so teuer
verkaufen damit ist wichtiger wirkt so
wir sind teuer das heißt wir sind gut
und gesund wie gesund auch hinter sein
kann
es ist auf jeden fall musiker und
schokoladiger das ist nicht so wer
geschmack jeder der schumacher hatte
weiß wie lecker ist mein mann ist das
lecker viel luftiger und kann absolut
nicht mit dem original mithalten
gewonnen hat das original hatte und nun
der kampf auf den alle gewartet haben
karibus gegen vegane gummibärchen haribo
gummibärchen sind ja wegen ihrer
gelatine nicht mal vegetarisch jetzt
kommt hier die wiegands gummibärchen
oder süße lippi vegan um die ecke harry
muss kosten 95 cent die tüte 129 das
sind nur 30 cent mehr ungefähr machte
treffen wir erstmal das normal
haribo gummibärchen mit den gummibärchen
auf den veganen kumpel wenn ich jetzt
gespannt schaut komplett anders man
schmeckt überhaupt nicht gut bei der
konsistenz kann ich noch ein auge
zudrücken aber der geschmack ist
wirklich scheiße und somit hat haribo
den punkt geholt ok freunde kommen wir
jetzt zur letzten runde kaugummi vegan
bio fairtrade versus original
süßungsmittel somit kaum machte
süßungsmittel lösungsmitteln füllstoff
kallinchen vater herum kann bei
übermäßigem verzehr abführend wirkt hier
ist drin
rott zuckersirup kaumasse glukose agaven
nix und mit aroma hier ist nicht nur ein
teil der zutaten drin wir hier drin sind
noch nicht was über kaugummi gelesen ob
das jetzt ungesund sein sollen oder beim
verzehr aber das wirkt wie eine sehr
gesunde bio variante von kaugummis falls
etwas wissen schreibt wendy kommentare
ist kaugummi und bis 1 euro 29 für die
originalen extra kaugummi von 2 eur 29
für die bio variante es ist ein dicker
kaugummi blog da kann man sich dann so
theile abreißen einmal das original
kaugummi ist tut mir leid wenn ihr leute
beim kaugummikauen nicht zuschauen
könnte sehr schön mit sich ja mag ich
gerne aber wir interessieren uns noch
viel mehr für dieses braune quadrat wie
schmeckt bio fairtrade den kaugummi
ich liebe die konsistenz wenn liebe es
biologisch abbaubar wie blätter klebt
nicht schont die umwelt schützt den
letzten regenwald mexikos durch
nachhaltige bewirtschaftung direkt und
fair gehandelt sie unterstützen mehr als
50 kooperativen mit über 2.000 schicke
los und deren familien ich find's super
mein gewinner des tages bio kaugummi was
absolut bio und fairtrade ist und
supergeil mund sich anfühlt what she
said das ergebnis vier punkte fürs team
vegan und fünf punkte fürs team original
ehrlich gesagt hätte ich nicht gedacht
dass die vegane produkte so viele punkte
reinholen weil der preis ja doch immer
schon recht hoch war und ich dachte das
original besser schnell aber was man
echt sagen kann ist dass kekse in der
veganen version irgendwie viel besser
schmecken knuspriger vollmundiger süße
leckerei weiß ich nicht genau was man
jetzt alles sagen sollte und ich frage
mich wirklich warum kosten vegane
produkte so viel mehr im endeffekt wird
nur eine zutat ausgetauscht und ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass das so viel
teurer ist also glaube ich doch schon
dass es halt noch daran liegt dass
vegane produkte so selten sind und sie
sich deswegen das auch leisten können
weil sie nicht so dieses freie markt den
haben wir jetzt die originalen beide
milka schokolade muss sich halt gegen
all die schokolade und links und alles
so behaupten aber vegane produkte die
stehen ja noch meistens für sich da so
hier kriegen
melbourne bons für 100 euro und die
schnecken nicht mal jungs nicht die
einzigen haben natürlich hat dieser
kleine test gefallen und wenn ja dann
einen daumen nach oben
darüber würde ich mich sehr freuen
aktiviert die glocke hier sind noch zwei
weitere videos und habt ihr schonmal
vegane süßigkeiten ausprobiert seid ihr
etwa veganer oder fleisch ist ihr
produkt vegetarisch schreibt man die
kommentare so eure meinung dazu
ich hoffe ihr diskutiert wieder ganz
lange darüber bis dann tschüss